if it's another boy I'm like oh my gosh
how am I going to love another boy how I
love my shy you know it's but maybe a
little girl will be different but I
think we just we wouldn't know till
we're there and we're definitely looking
forward to more
um I think you know I come from a
sibling family you know Peter has a
sibling and we sort of now realize that
the the huge value of that and I'm also
looking at this kid I'm like if he's the
only one he's gonna be this over
attended to yeah with the grandparents
yeah grandparents and us well it looks
like shy is officially getting a sibling
because Peta Murgatroyd and Maxim
schmerkovsky are expecting their second
child it's going really well we're very
excited the Dancing with the Stars pro
announced the news with immense Joy
quote after two years of constant
struggle and heartache three
miscarriages and a failed Embryo
transfer we have a healthy bun in the
oven yeah it's a great feeling Peter
calls the pregnancy a shock because she
and Max conceive right before they were
set to do another round of IVF
success it's done it's done
guys I know there's no promises but
I think this is the most excited I've
been in
a very long time it's a process they
were candid about during peta's first
round yeah I honestly you know you hear
the horror stories about it you know
marriage is breaking up all that stuff
you know it's it's
uh pretty dramatic but um I it hasn't
gone there but it is definitely yeah
there's been some times where I'm like
oh my gosh like I can't believe I'm
doing this but
honestly we're good
um this is the path for us it was
skeptic to the openness of it and how
open do we want to be and now I realize
that there is the reason why people do
struggle with it is because it's such a
taboo to talk yeah and a lot of people
need to understand that maybe you know
it would bypass a lot of the drama if
you know that there's this option once
you face the situation instead of
sticking in it
for too long sometimes you know you go
straight to the solution and uh and this
is what what I think Peter is trying to
show it feels good to share it and it's
not like a look at me look
finally I can say something and not feel
closed off and not feel bad about it and
not feel alone so it feels good as for
this miracle baby's due date well he or
she is expected to be dancing their way
into the world in June I just want to be
a good dad and a great husband and you
know and after that it's whatever the
life throws at us right so let's just be
open and and hug a loved one congrats to
the soon-to-be parents of two
foreign